I believe that your personality creates
your personal reality and in order to
change your personal reality your life
it means then that on some level we have
to change because nothing changes in our
life unless we change so if people have
understand that 90 of the thoughts that
they think every day are the same
thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the very same
feelings and emotions and those same
emotions influence our very same
thoughts and our biology our circuitry
our neurochemistry our hormones our gene
expression stays the same because we're
the same but the repetition of firing
and wiring the same circuits in our
brain in the same way causes us to
create a very finite set of circuitry
that becomes our identity and our
personality and nerve cells that fire
together wire together which means you
keep doing it it gets easier for them to
fire and they run more automatically
need motivation Watch Attack can with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I struggle to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's learn from one of the best
Joe dispenza and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy
so it turns out 95 percent of Who We Are
by our midlife is a set of memorized uh
behaviors unconscious habits hardwired
thoughts and attitudes
conditioned emotions that are so
familiar to us that it doesn't even feel
like uh fear or it doesn't feel like
sadness is just who we are
so it usually takes crisis or trauma or
disease or diagnosis or lowest point in
your life where you're knocked to your
knees
and for that moment
you actually have a view of yourself
outside of yourself you can see yourself
from a different state that the facade
the the the the the whole illusion is
over and that's when a person really
begins to think about what they've been
thinking about they begin to notice how
they speak or how they act
and I think they begin to pay attention
to those feelings uh on a more regular
and conscious basis and the word
meditation I look this up because when I
started my journey I'm I'm very
scientifically minded the word
meditation the symbol means to become
familiar with
so
so then the first step to change if you
wanted to create a new life you have to
change it to change your personal
reality you have to change your
personality and the first step is
consciousness or becoming aware so the
moment you become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts the moment you
become aware of your automatic reflexive
habits and and your emotional reactions
the moment you can become so conscious
of those unconscious states of mind and
body
that you don't go unconscious again so
familiar with those States and how many
times do we have to forget or go
unconscious till we no longer forget or
go unconscious and we stay conscious
that's that's that's us lighting a match
in a dark place and most people when
they do meditation they they actually
think when those voices come up and when
the chatter starts and those emotions
start
they actually think that they're doing
their meditation wrong
and I want them to know that they're
actually doing it right because you're
coming up against those thoughts that
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by many people uh you all of a
sudden catch how you speak and people
say if I really want to be happy let's
think about this
I don't wanna I don't wanna complain I
don't want to blame I don't want to make
excuses I don't want to feel sorry for
myself I'm going to stop that now that's
breaking a habit of being yourself
that's a that takes a lot of energy and
a lot of awareness and and and our
environment then the circumstances our
environment are always available for us
to think and feel equal to everything in
our life you know so the environment for
many people as we said earlier controls
the way they think and feel so when they
respond to their co-worker when they
respond to the news when they respond to
the
um the the traffic in their life
uh that response causes them to return
back to those unconscious programs so
but sitting in a meditation and really
sitting in the fire and
believing that there's something on the
other side of that thought uh believing
that there's something on the other side
of some Behavior or some emotion that
feel makes us feel a certain way that's
that's stepping into the unknown and and
it takes
um
it takes us disconnecting from the
environment that's what meditation is
about playing music or hearing nothing
or closing your eyes and not eating not
smelling not tasting not feeling with
your body you're putting your body away
and you're not letting it be the mind or
the program you're making it sit still
you're training the animal right and and
a person starts feeling emotional and
they catch themselves
starting to feel those emotions instead
of letting that emotion Drive certain
thoughts or actions
that person settles the body down
uh in the meditation and brings it back
into the present moment and that's a
victory rule number two is be in charge
of your life well I think that uh if you
look at just the scientific model of how
we are
structured that by the time we're 35
years old we've done so many things
so many times that it becomes an
unconscious habit and 95 percent of who
we are is really unconscious thoughts uh
automatic habits emotional reactions
beliefs perceptions attitudes that
function pretty much behind the scenes
of our awareness
so the process of becoming conscious
of what you're unconscious about
yourself begins the process of change
so how you think how you act and how you
feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality that's it
so if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
you'd have to change your personality
which means you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it become aware of your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and then look at the emotions that
you've experienced that keep you
anchored to the Past
and really look at them and decide do
these emotions really belong in my
future
so when you begin to think differently
when you begin to act differently you
begin to feel differently your life is
going to change
so most people
like to wait for
a reason to change like a crisis or a
trauma
or a diagnosis from some disease and now
all of a sudden they realize that they
can't go on living the same life any
longer they have to change something
about themselves
okay
so I think that my message is why wait
for that trauma that when you teach
people
that they can begin to create a better
life for themselves and even improve
their health
and give them the tools on how to do it
it becomes more effective for everybody
you know here's the key
is that we are already wired to do this
we're always always in the process of
creation if we're truly relaxed and
beginning to think about what we want
for ourselves in our lives
when we're living in stress and we're
living in survival then it's not a time
to create so getting people out of those
survival States into more creative
States allows them to do it we're
innately wired to do rule number three
is control your attention if you're
reacting
if you're reacting to the problems in
your in your or that
that reality
changed no matter what you did you tried
you forced you prayed you hoped you
wished you hired people you fired people
you've forgiven you've done all those
things and still it hasn't changed
that's because the moment you come back
to your senses you're consciously or
unconsciously having certain thoughts
that are connected to that problem that
are producing a certain frequency or a
certain feeling and you're producing the
same energy every single day and your
life stays the same are you with me
still think about this
think about that problem in your life or
that condition is that has never changed
what are your thoughts about it
it's not something pleasant is it
and what are the feelings associated
with it there aren't feelings that you
don't typically want to live by but you
live by those feelings every single day
yes or no
so then you're reacting consciously or
unconsciously to the thought of the
problem or the actual problem over and
over again you are broadcasting the
electromagnetic signature into your
field but if you're creating and those
thoughts are these lower frequency
thoughts then you have very little
effect on matter so now you got to go
make the problem happy you gotta go
change it with you you got to get your
identity or personality involved in it
are you with me still come on
so then we found out
in the research that we've done and we
now know there's a formula
that when a person takes all of their
attention off their body
all of their attention off the people in
their life all their attention of their
things they own their cell phone their
computer their car every object or
material thing take their attention off
their home where they sleep where they
work they take all the tension off where
they're even sitting and they take their
attention off the predictable future or
their familiar past and they find The
Sweet Spot of the generous present
moment then they're disinvesting all of
their attention and energy out of this
three-dimensional reality and they're
moving in the opposite direction towards
the unified field
and now when they become nobody no one
no thing nowhere and no time they have
to pass through
different layers of emotions that are
have memories different frequencies that
are carrying different in that's
carrying different information and they
gotta pass through these layers that
have become their identity and most
people don't know how to make their way
through so they do a little bit and then
they come back to their identity the
same personality most of you almost all
of you have traversed through these
frequencies and reached the point where
you can become nobody no one no thing
nowhere in no time and that is the
moment you are pure Consciousness and
you now are no longer associating with
anything in three-dimensional reality
and if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you're
disinvesting all of your attention and
energy out of this three-dimensional
reality off of everything that's known
and you're making a choice to go to a
field where all possibilities exist the
unknown the quantum field rule number
four is inspire people if you study the
Neuroscience of culture you know it's so
so you unique because we have we share
the same biology we share the same brain
and because we share the same biology
and the same brain we we have certain
Universal traits that are that are
unique to human beings we smile on we're
happy we frown and we're sad we sleep at
night for the most part we grab a stick
with an opposing thumb so structure and
function are highly related and those
are Universal traits and then we have
our individual traits and that's kind of
like how the brain is wired right that's
like our fingerprint as opposed to our
hand right so
we have an individual series of traits
and that make us unique and we have our
Universal traits but what Bridges the
universality of us the commonalities and
beings with our individuality and that's
culture and culture really is defined
for the most part by the past what has
worked over Generations or Traditions
that have sustained the culture based on
one thing
and that one thing is in environment so
a culture in Northern Mongolia is
certainly different than a culture in
central Mexico because it's a different
environment and those different Customs
that are created from that environment
allow that culture to sustain itself so
look at look at great people in history
that that change the culture whether it
was Gandhi whether it was William
Wallace whether it was Joan of Arc
whether it was Martin Luther King
whoever it was that changed the culture
what they did really well is they showed
people that there was an alternative
future that they could actually believe
or perceive in their mind now you can't
see that future if you're living by the
same emotions of the past and for most
people they live by the emotions of the
past what you have to do is you got to
get people out of their resting state
they have to become inspired they have
to become enthusiastic and Theos filled
with God they have to become motivated
in some way they have to be moved and
when they are moved emotionally then
that that that energy that emotion
causes them to see the same future as
that leader sees and you when you get
people seeing that same future and they
have that clear intention and you
combine that with a different emotion
you're changing people's state of being
now get enough people doing that
and what he what happens is you get an
emergent Consciousness an emergence in
biology is such a phenomenal thing
because when you see a group of birds or
a flock of birds flying in the same
direction or a school of fish moving
together they appear as a larger
organism when you study that principle
and biology you think that there's a
leader that everybody's following that
it's a top-down phenomenon in fact it's
not it's a bottom-up phenomenon and
everybody's leaving leading everybody's
behaving in the same way and the
appearance of a larger organism becomes
more sustainable for that species so
we have such a stigma in our minds that
if you lead with too much passion you're
going to get it in the end whether
you're Jesus Christ or Abraham Lincoln
or uh William Moss whoever it was the
the outcome for truth is usually you
lose your life
but the real question is what if
everybody's leading you just can't take
out everybody now so so this is a really
important time because the emergent
Consciousness that has to take place has
to be built on principles and the
principles that people can actually wrap
their mind around
they have to keep their mind on it for a
period of time where they're not
distracted by technology they're not
distracted by Tick Tock and they're not
distracted by social media and they're
not distracted by the news that that
that the the eminent condition of the
world right now and the way things are
going based on self-interests
are all based on survival and you can
control people
when you control their emotions and when
you control their emotions you control
their attention and if you can capture a
person's attention you can capture their
energy because where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and so you could actually program people
to do anything
based on the emotion that they feel and
fear is a great emotion to cause people
to rely on some authoritative figure to
lead them away so
if there's a new Consciousness that
emerges that that is based on not fruits
and nuts and not uh you know not on
crystals not on colonics not on any of
those things but this is game time this
is where something else has to be born
in human beings that has already innate
in us and that is the power to organize
as a species when we begin to heal one
another when we begin to inform one
another and begin to respect one another
when we begin to shine from one another
when we begin to stand up for one
another one begin to abilities and then
damage
two people that there are other ways of
doing things and share that right
information I think an emerging
Consciousness will actually take place
and
God I think this is the time in history
more than ever uh where where it matters
the most also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is practice gratitude
well there's two really paradigms two
specific paradigms of reality that are
about what's called Newtonian physics
which is causing fact that you know
something happens to us in our
environment I think but an experience
happens it changes us internally and
then we react to that condition and when
we react to the condition we begin to
function at effect of something outside
of us if something good happens to us
and we react positively then we give
thanks after the experience happens
really but either way we're pretty much
victims of Destiny the quantum model of
reality says that mind and matter aren't
separately that that subjective mind
somehow has an effect on the objective
world so then
if you begin to piece this together
you can have a clear intention of what
you want
but then to move into the state of how
you would feel if it already happened
gratitude is an emotional signature that
the event is already done so if you can
teach your body emotionally what it
feels like
to have the event already happen and you
can get in touch with that then your
body is the unconscious mind doesn't
know the difference between the
experience that produces the emotion and
the emotion that you fabricate or create
by thought alone and when we move into a
state of being where mind and body are
working together for our thoughts and
feelings are aligned so there are
biological changes that happen in the
brain and body and we move into that
state of being and when we're in that
state of being the universe begins to
organize itself to reflect a new state
of being rule number six is get out of
survival mode when you're in the state
of survival
you're not going to learn you're not
going to want to create you're not going
to want to go within you're not going to
want to open your heart you're not going
to want to be vulnerable it's not the
time to do that in stress it's time to
run to hide or to fight and so people
spend 70 percent of their life living in
the state and as they begin to get
caught up in these chemicals what they
start doing is out of the infinite
possibilities in the quantum field that
they can begin to create in stress you
will select the worst case scenario
and when you select the worst case
scenario you're in survival because in
survival if you prepare for the worst
there's better chances of surviving so
people are always picking the worst
reality in their mind and combining a
thought with the emotion and their
conditioning their body into a genetic
Destiny how many people are with me
so then
separation means I'm here and you're
there and if you look any different than
me then I'm going to experience a little
bit more separation and if you have a
different skin color I hear a different
race or you you look different than me
then I'm going to experience more
separation and then there's me here one
point of Consciousness and you there
another point of Consciousness but then
there's me here and there's my dreams
and where do we place our dreams way out
there because we experience time linear
so we make an estimate in our mind it's
going to take me a lot of time to get
what I want so here's one point of
Consciousness and then your dreams are
another point of Consciousness way over
there and it's going to cause you to
drag your body through space every
single day to go to work to pay off all
the dreams that you're creating because
your matter trying to change matter rule
number seven is change your thinking I
just think that there's more to reality
than we perceive and I think it's an
instinct in our mind it's an intuition
in our heart that never seems to go away
and I think it's that feeling that
brings people to to to Really that
process of discovery they may not be
able to explain it put it into words but
they feel it and they felt that their
entire lives and what that feeling is is
that this isn't it this cannot be the
end this it just can't be so and so what
do I find so promising is that
uh I said to my scientific team the
other day I said I can't believe this is
the truth I really cannot believe this
is the truth I mean what was once
considered pseudoscience we now have
data my one of our top scientists did a
presentation a couple weeks ago and his
last line this is a very well published
guy 175 papers his last line is you are
what you think that was his last line I
looked at him and I thought who is this
Buddha on the stage like I cannot
believe rule number eight is create your
personality we can begin to make
measurable changes uh in reality by
allowing ourselves to create a new
personality so if you begin to see that
what you're doing inside of you changing
how you think and feel produces an
effect outside of you you're no longer
uh in a victim of cause and effect but
now you're causing enough so in order to
explain the answer to that question you
have to merge several different
idealisms from quantum physics to
neuroscience and mind to the
neuroendocrinology of emotions how
emotions signal genes you know genes
prepare the body you know for its
Destiny so I think the best way to
describe it is is that when we move into
a new state of being and we're no longer
thinking acting and feeling in the same
way there should be physiological and
physical changes as a result of it and
if we just simply make different choices
because we're being differently we're
certainly going to head to in the future
rule number nine is sync your brain with
your heart our sexuality our consumption
of food our our ability to use our will
to overcome the conditions in our
environment most people live by these
centers here these are centers of
awareness centers of energy and each one
every thought that you have produces a
frequency so this is what we call the
zero point field it is the Quantum field
the unified field the energy that
connects everything material it is the
consciousness of the all in all it is
Oneness wholeness Universal Mind
infinite intelligence zero point field
the unified field Source Observer the
void the fertile void all possibilities
the Eternal now the infinite unknown the
very life force that holds everything
together and it's a unifying field and
scientists have been trying to unify the
principles and the energy of the
universe to explain how matter exists
are you with me still
so energy then the zero point field
slows down in frequency and it reaches a
certain point and at this level there's
an explosion called The Big Bang and all
of a sudden energy can't slow any
anymore before it divides and becomes
polarized and the patterns of everything
material exist at the speed of light and
it's the patterns then that slow energy
down to take form and structure that
ultimately appears matter now
all of us the Divine aspect of ourselves
came from this Universal intelligence
and we came all the way down into
density and this is the realm of our
senses and we can experience the
three-dimensional reality with our
senses and we spend our whole life being
a somebody or having some type of body
or knowing someone or being someone
owning certain things living somewhere
in some time and this becomes the
identity are you with me still
so then
people then spend the majority of their
life living in this way and they
experience from matter the greatest
separation from the unified field
here is source and if you're living as a
body local in space and time you're
experiencing a separation between you as
a Consciousness and the consciousness of
the unified field so when you're living
in a body and space and time it takes a
long time for your dreams to happen are
you with me still so if you're thinking
certain thoughts and certain thoughts
produce certain feelings you're taking a
thought and you're beginning to store it
as energy or emotion in one of these
centers and most people are thinking in
these first three centers and when they
do they're storing energy in their first
three centers and their bodies being
conditioned to be the mind
it takes opening this Center to begin to
the creative process this is the center
of Oneness this is the center of
wholeness this is the union of polarity
and Duality and if you can't get energy
into your heart then for the most part
then it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart to begin to affect the
nature of reality to begin to affect
matter are you with me still
so then every thought that you think
produces a frequency and most people's
frequencies most people's thoughts are
in this realm right here and would make
sense then if they're thinking flower
thought frequencies then it's going to
take a long time for their dreams to
come true and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is get outside of time we really think
that you know everything's going to be
handed to us or we can get whatever we
want nothing's wrong with that that's
really cool that's really great but in
the creative process
you actually have to get outside of time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known the
present moment is the unknown that is
where all possibilities exist so yes
there is a function of three-dimensional
reality in technology where more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time certainly there's some type of
energetic thing that's taking place in
so many ways and to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be that's what I believe so if you want
to be a victim get ready because it's
going to get really good for you because
that energy is more available if you
want to heal wow there's a lot of people
healing now and they're using that
energy instrumentally in a positive way
so so yes there's a quickening that's
taking place and it's creating quite a
contrast or extremes that are taking
place in reality and the more extreme it
gets the more unstable the system right
so uh governments
um
uh journalism uh education religion
medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
uh I think that amazing things happen
and that's exactly what we're
discovering over and over again in just
witnessing the the science
is absolutely supporting that that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more unlimited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind
86 percent of the people in the Western
World the first thing they do when they
wake up in the morning is grab their
cell phone that's almost nine out of ten
people so more than likely there's a
good percentage of people that are
watching this podcast or listening to it
that do that and when they reach for
their cell phone and they look through
their Facebook and their Instagram and
their Tick Tock and their emails and
their uh Twitter and do all of that
they're connecting to everything that's
known in their life they're actually
making sure that they're connected in a
certain way
in place of that
you can still do that but before you
grab unconsciously for your phone and
start changing your chemicals in your
body it would be such a great idea to
sit down and before you start your day
just review the thoughts you don't want
to think
review the behaviors you really want to
change about yourself just review them
just go over them in your mind
re review the emotions that you feel the
most in a day and just remember that
those emotions aren't loving to you just
just review them in the beginning just
so that you're aware of them have to
change you'll start becoming aware of
them and when once you can observe them
you're no longer the program once you're
conscious of them you're no longer
unconscious right you're out of the
program
before you start the day ask yourself
what how do I want to think today how do
I want to feel how do I want to behave I
mean what would greatness look like what
would love look like today what could I
do
that would be really cool for me at the
end of the day say wow so I had a good
day today what what would make me feel
that way and if you can't find an answer
to that start reading who reads anymore
read a book I read so many books a week
I know I'm that way too so read
something about you want to be wealthy
read a book about someone who became
wealthy and get get real and realize
they may have failed 50 times before
they actually pulled it off or what were
their characteristics what were their
traits What made them it's not wasn't
about their wealth it was about who they
became that's the key right so so so
fill your brain with a little knowledge
and then just start asking yourself
what's the greatest expression of myself
that I can be today and and and rehearse
it rehearse how you're going to be and
and then if if it leads to a different
Choice that's the unknown and just know
that it's not going to be predictable
it's going to be a little uncomfortable
that's where the magic happens if you
can stay relaxed and awake in the
unknown
things get pretty exciting when you're
back to the known you're back to the
familiar don't expect anything to change
in your life and if you say it's that
person or that circumstance
ah you default and went back to the
program of the victim allowing your
outer environment controlling your
thoughts and feelings if you truly do
this well
this is what I discovered
if I truly feel the feelings of my
future before they occur and I live in
that state I'm no longer looking for it
to happen how could I look for it if I
feel like it already has right so I try
to stay in that state because then I
don't then I'm not separate from it and
that tends to be when the magic happens
there there's no control anymore there's
no predicting there's no perfectionism
there's none of all there is is just
kind of an experiment like I'm
experimenting to see if I changed my
thoughts and feelings if my life will
change and that should be the experiment
everybody has and and and do it with
with curiosity and do it with just
seeing if if the experiment works if it
doesn't change something else about
yourself until it starts to work that's
how powerful we are you could actually
like the story We Tell ourselves
is how we perceive the world
and so then then when we create the
difficulties in our life it reaffirms
the belief that life is hard that it's
really someone out there that's doing it
to us that it's a circumstance in the
past that created this okay let's take
away the person that did it let's shoot
him to the Moon Let's uh let's erase
your past now what are you going to do
now I am you still you still got to do
something right you're still alive and
I say we already know how to do this we
already know how to do this we're wired
to be creators we're wired to do this
the thing that stops us for the most
part in doing it is really the hormones
of stress because living in stress
constantly is living in survival and
living in survivals living in emergency
in an emergency it's not a time to
create an emergency it's not a time to
open your heart it's not a time to learn
it's not even a time to sit still so
most people then that are living in
stress and living in survival they can't
believe in a future yet because it's not
a time to create so getting people to
that point
where they make up their mind and they
make up their mind enough to begin to
think there's got to be a better way
there's got to be something else
that Awakening process typically happens
when people reach their lowest
denominator
they hit rock bottom because then they
can see themselves Through The Eyes of
somebody else you're you feel so altered
you're not returning any text you feel
so altered you want to go to dinner with
your buddies you feel so altered you
know you don't want to watch your
favorite TV show you're just you're just
disconnected and that's when you start
observing yourself
but my message is why wait for that I
mean you can learn and change in pain
and suffering or you can learn and
change enjoy an inspiration if you're
waking up every morning being defined by
a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past and you get up and
you're inspired from an elevated self
now instead of a limited self you could
observe the old cell from an elevated
State instead of that diminished State
and people are doing that so they are
aware
of those thoughts and yes it takes uh
effort and if it was easy everybody
would be doing it but just because you
have a thought doesn't necessarily mean
it's true and when you start looking and
observing those thoughts
um I think you are like Gandalf because
Gandalf also said you know you may not
pass you know when he meant like that's
kind of severity when it comes to how we
we make up our mind about things that's
the kind of energy or intention
begins to create the biggest volume of
change in our life and I've interviewed
thousands of people in our work that
have
healed from really serious health
conditions and I would say about 90 of
them when I asked them so what happened
the first thing they say all the time is
I just made up my mind I just made up my
mind I was going to do this and they
made a decision
with such firm intention that the
amplitude of that decision
carried a level of energy that was
greater than the hardwired programs in
their brain and the emotional
conditioning in their body and the
choice that they made caused their body
to respond to a new mind in fact the
choice they made became a moment that
they would never forget it was an event
and the stronger the emotion they felt
the more they paid attention to the
choice and in a sense they were
remembering their future and the body
emotionally was getting a sampling a
taste of the future and they are lying
to that future and
that's when the body's healing began
that's when the miracle started right in
that moment that's how powerful really
are now what if you did that every day
what if you made up your mind every
single day you weren't going to get up
from your meditation until you were that
person you wanted to be game on now
because you'd have to do battle
with all the things that are not
consistent with it and that's exactly
how our brain works so then if you want
to be wealthy you can't feel lack you
want to be a master you can't judge your
co-worker you want to be like somebody
great in history then you better execute
peace in every area of your life that's
that's the law so
you take the prayer out on the road now
you take the prayer you're the living
example of the prayer that's where
that's where it matters the most and
that's when people start getting
suspicious and say shun man you change
your medication I mean you're looking
way too happy all of a sudden well
you're not relying on anything outside
of you to bring you Joy you're you're
you're overcoming yourself every day and
people say to me well why do you do your
meditations in the morning I always say
easy because if I can overcome myself at
the beginning of the day the rest of the
day is easy right because that's the
biggest that's the biggest Master right
is the self look people can create all
kinds of wealth and they can create all
kinds of abundance they can have the
cars the homes and everything but if
they can't be present right to enjoy
them I've sat with billionaires and
they've looked me in the eye and said
we're all miserable same here we're all
miserable and and and and and and and so
then at what point do you have to wait
uh to change does it have to be that
lowest point or or or can you learn and
change in a state of joy and inspiration
instead of instead of pain and suffering
and that that becomes the art right so
then
to change then is to be greater than the
habituations the drives and the emotions
that have been conditioned in the body
to change is to be greater than the
conditions in our environment that every
person every object everything in our
life has a neurological Network
associated with them they're knowns
because we've experienced them and we
have an emotion associate with them so
you if you're not being defined by a
vision of the future
you're left with the memories of the
past and you see your ex and you're
going to see your ex through the memory
of your past neurologically and it's
going to elicit an emotional response
and you're thinking and feeling equal to
your environment your life's not going
to change so then the next question is
how could I overcome that condition that
with my ex can I actually forgive could
I actually open my heart can I actually
the reason we do this is because the
stronger the emotion we feel towards
someone or something in our life the
more we pay attention to them and where
we place our attention is where we place
our energy and so then we're giving our
power away to that person or
circumstance that's vital life force you
could use to change the person who's
sitting in the meditation
and they want to quit this is they're
thinking they're doing their meditation
wrong I want to tell you you're doing it
right that's the defining moment right
and you lower the volume to that emotion
I guarantee you'll take your attention
off that person and sooner or later when
the body finally settles down and you
get Beyond it you're going to take your
power back and that's building your own
electromagnetic field now you have
energy to heal now you have energy great
we measured this now you have energy for
for creation I consider myself a pretty
open-minded person I mean I have a
pretty good meter too like I I
have a truth meter that like I just I'm
a I'm a practical person yeah I want to
talk about Quantum superimposition if it
doesn't change my life in any way I want
to know how it's going to affect my life
I'm a pragmatist so I consider myself a
pretty open-minded person but I have you
know I'm skeptical about things because
I want to challenge them
in a way that I think it really helps
people right so
when I saw you know some of the dramatic
changes take place
I was I I I I I never thought in my
lifetime
that I would be witnessing what I'm in
what I witness and every single
week-long event that we've done and
we've done 30 of them now and it's never
been a disappointment there's just a
transformative thing that takes place
that is way bigger than me so when you
see a person with a stroke who's blind
in the quarter of their Vision or has
paralysis and can't move an arm
and you see that Vision completely
restored and then you see the scan that
shows there's no longer any blemish or
damage to the visual field
you just you can't go back
to business as usual you can't go back
to being the same person you once you
know
you can't not know and and and it's so
beautiful because
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
is noticing and paying attention
so when you see a person who has a
transformation and you see the science
that says in a week-long event
there'll be over 600 metabolic changes
in 75 percent of the audience for the
better in a one-week event
when you when you know that
you're now you're aware of another
possibility that may not be the
possibility that we think is free will
to choose from gnomes this is now you're
stepping outside
and when a person shows up and believes
in themselves and does the work
they're believing in possibility you
cannot believe in possibility
and and and believe in yourself not
believe in yourself you got to believe
in yourself and believe in possibility
you got to believe in possibility you
got to believe in yourself
so
for me personally I I it's way bigger
than me I'm very humbled on a regular
basis every time I get another
testimonial
uh I say this person is speaking the
truth
and and it's it's a footprint
for somebody else to step into and
I think the world needs that more than
ever so for me
um
my greatest passion my greatest joy I
think there's some there's something in
US Glenn that's so empathetic uh now
we're we have universities that are
studying we're studying people that can
be healed remotely you don't even need
to be in their presence if you
understand the science of quantum
physics and you understand how to do it
you can hit a Target
and heal another person at a distance
and there it is and there it's gone
now when you see that occur
there's some kind of empathy I I drop in
on the calls of these people that show
up every single day of their life to
heal another person and they do at least
three or four a day
and these people they're not doing it
because they want to be a Healer
they're doing it because well how they
feel when they see a mother who's
comes on the zoom call and says my
daughter was you know a handicapped from
birth she had a traumatic birth she's
listless unresponsive never looked at
her brothers and all of a sudden this
kid is smiling at her brothers and
trying to talk and you watch the
people on the zoom call that are the
healers you see everywhere all in tears
there's this empathy that takes place
where we're contributing as a species to
one another that we were part of
somebody's transformation we gave in
some way another one of us is better in
this kind of feeling of empathy this
feeling of connection is so profound
that goes against all those survival and
stress emotions that create Division and
polarity and separation and and distrust
and and so
that's when Community starts coming
together that's when we start to
collaborate cooperate and it and it's
got to be from the heart so
I'm super hopeful about
um well what what we're doing I think
we've been programmed quite a bit uh in
with our relationship with money and we
have a relationship with everything
known in our environment you have a
relationship a neurological Network in
your brain to for your parents for your
cell phone for your computer where you
live where you've lived in the past what
you're going to do tomorrow that for the
most part the brain is a reflection of
everything that we know right so along
with that is our relationship with money
and I I feel like I have a really good
relationship with money because I work
on having a really good relationship
with everything in my life did you
always have a good relationship with
mine I think so I think so I've never
really lived in lack that just wasn't
part of it even when I went to college
and I had to take out student loans and
stuff I always figured out a way to
always be a little bit ahead of the
curve and so so
let's back up and just look at how
people form beliefs because yes most
beliefs
um are created from past experiences
right so uh children uh when they're uh
in their early ages their brain waves
are very slow like their brain waves are
in Alpha when they're like seven to
twelve they're in Theta when they're
like two to six years old and and
they're in Delta like when they're when
they're you know newborn to two years
old and so these brainwave States uh are
states that were really suggestible to
information so when we hear information
we believe it and we accept it we
believe it we surrender to it as if it's
the truth without analyzing it because
there's no analytical facilities yet
right the analytical mind starts around
12 or so 7 to 12 and that analytical
mind is actually what creates a barrier
between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind so 412 roughly what we
see how how we model our parents
behavior is all being programmed
subconsciously right and so so that's
really really important because if you
heard money is the root of all evil
uh money is bad
only certain people are allowed to make
money you have to work hard to make
money this is how you got to do it and
that becomes the foundations
subconsciously like let's like write
recording an audio file you just keep
recording that audio file it becomes a
subconscious program right so a lot of
people have a relationship with money
based on either what they've been told
or what they've experienced in their
outer environment right so
so then we gain information from our
environment and the stronger the emotion
we feel from experiences in our lives
the more altered we feel inside of us
the more the brain freezes a frame and
takes a picture and that snapshot is
called the memory So based on an emotion
based on emotion the emotion Alters our
internal state so you're going along as
Lewis feeling really good and all of a
sudden you have this trauma you have
this crisis you have this shock and all
of a sudden you have this dramatic
change in your internal State and your
senses get heightened and then you
freeze the frame and you associate this
internal state with whatever it is
that's causing it right and that's how
we create long-term memories we have
such great evidence to show that there's
something very profound that happens
when a person has a transcendental
moment and they have an interaction with
energy when they hit those elegant
States
they sometimes come to events as sick
we draw their blood at the beginning of
the event their event and they we see
the what happens to their brain we see
what happens to their heart and we know
this person has had a profound moment
and we draw their blood and we measure
everything afterwards
if we take the plasma of those
individuals
as an example and we take a pseudovirus
that looks just like SARS cov2
or we actually take now recently we
actually did the actual SARS virus and
we put that virus
in the presence of that person that
advanced meditator that had that
transcendental moment
there's a consistent resistance to the
virus the virus cannot enter the cell of
that person
in people that are novice meditators and
they come to a week-long event some of
the virus enters their cells some of the
virus stays out so there's somewhat of
an immunity in all the controls they get
infected
all right so we know now that there's
some agent some cofactor in the blood
when a person has this moment
so we've gone through some extensive
scientific studies and we actually
isolated the very protein
that stops the virus from entering the
cell
and if we take that protein
and we put it in the infected plasma of
the controls
all of the infected controls become
uninfected now we're not getting that
from anywhere out there we're actually
finding it in someone
who has had a moment where they've
interacted with Oneness with wholeness
and whether it's there's some change in
energy in the blood and there's some
proteins being released but we're
starting to discover there's some
powerful agents when this occurs take
the blood of that advanced meditator and
put it
ate their plasma and put it in a uterine
cancer cell and and the cancer cells the
mitochondria the powerhouses of the
cells are switched on and they're
pumping out a lot of energy that's why
they're almost Immortal if we take the
blood of the advanced meditator and we
substitute to a uterine cancer cell 75
of the energy
comes out of the mitochondria takes the
wind out of the cells
take the plasma of that at the same
advanced meditator
and put it on a neuron that has
Alzheimer's and produces the amyloid
protein and there's a significant change
in the gene expression of the
Alzheimer's Gene
take that person then and subject their
blood to the variance
the Lambda variant the Delta variant the
beta variance and the same thing occurs
they're resistant
uh to the virus now what does that mean
okay
if you really think about this
it would suggest
that there's very dramatic environmental
changes taking place from a scientific
standpoint
anybody who sees this kind of gene
expression change or change in biology
they would say oh my God it suggests
that there's a dramatic change in the
environment the problem is is the person
is sitting in a ballroom in a hotel
there's not a lot a lot of things going
on in a ballroom in a hotel it's not a
changing environment where is all that
change coming from
information from the field
so we have great great testimony in our
community of people that have reversed
all kinds of things and people have
created all kinds of wealth and created
all kinds of mystical moments
and we have really great evidence
in our scientific studies and evidences
the loudest voice it is the voice that
makes the biggest difference so
what kind of human being then
who has trained themselves
to no longer be victim to their
environment if I said to you Emilio why
what's up with you today and you say I'm
sad because of this person or this
circumstance I would say oh we mean that
person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel in the way
you think well anything that's
controlling the way you feel the way you
think you're victim to
so then when things are good you feel
good when things are bad you feel bad
right and if you feel bad then you look
for something out there to make this
feeling go away but then when the when
the novelty or the event is over here
comes that feeling again and you got to
go chase something else well
the response for many people to their
environment is actually weakening their
body the stress response they react to
some event and their reaction to the
event is actually weakening the organism
now short term it's cool all organisms
can handle that
but the long-term effects of that just
diminishes or taps the body's resources
of vital energy there's no energy to
heal there's no energy for growth and
repair so what we're suggesting
is that when the person becomes less
victim to their environment and
realizing that they're more of the
creator of their environment and they're
less the response to the environment
weakens them less
because I know how to self-regulate and
change
they'll be less susceptible to things in
their environment large or small and
creating a life
that is Meaningful for a person someone
who's young as you and you start seeing
that you're actually creating it
you every time you get feedback of
breadcrumb from the universe saying
Emilio keep going keep your keep your
head down keep going you're running
gonna run into something big all of
those things are convincing you that you
are not
the victim to your life that you're
actually the creator of your life and
people who actually do this not that you
react the question is how long you react
and teaching people how to move out of
those States
and back into homeostasis back into
balance by self-regulating with their
eyes open getting so good at doing it in
their meditation with their eyes closed
that they could actually do it with
their eyes open in their life now it's a
different game so
get enough people
uh in the world becoming less reactive
to their environment they're less
controlled by their environment and the
side effect of that is there's a huge
change in our biology huge I can I could
say right now with certainty I can say
that if people commit
to say as an example seven days of of an
event that we do I can say there will be
so many biological changes that take
place in their body we have the evidence
that says that but we have such a
profound hope
uh for Humanity in what we're
discovering there's a biology to
personal change and transformation so we
have this emerging youth that that has
to resolve the problems that have been
created by this past generation from a
greater level of Consciousness and that
means when everybody else is angry and
everybody else is frustrated you're
going to have to show compassion
when everybody else is fearful and
worried you're gonna have to show
courage but everybody else is racing and
rushing and competing to succeed and
climbing over each other to get to the
top you're gonna have to learn how to be
in the present moment and draw to you
and I think if you do that in the
beginning
it feels unnatural because everybody
else is doing something else
but how do we become Supernatural unless
we start doing the things that feel
unnatural so anger is not going to
resolve it that's actually what's
created Prejudice is not going to
resolve it that's what's created it
greed is not going to resolve it that's
what exactly actually has created it and
so
we're in a time right now right before
our eyes we're watching the world in
many ways that experience such extreme
polarity
that the wobbling of polarity is
breaking the system right and it's
creating chaos this disorder chaos is
the no longer the known as we're in a
big unknown right now
so when there's brain and heart
coherence God we have such incredible
data they could take if I trained you on
how to do that you could be running
around doing a thousand different things
and I could say Emilio sit down you got
15 minutes uh to synchronize your heart
to your brain we do this all the time
and whether the young guys running
around chasing this one-year-old
two-year-old kid one of my staff is
running around doing a thousand
different things sit down they sit down
and all of a sudden music starts and you
see them start moving in and all of a
sudden you see this beautiful low
frequency take place in the heart and
once we see that it starts to build you
see the parasympathetic nervous system
go up which means either relaxing and
then the bio sympathetic nervous system
goes down and the sympathetic nervous
system goes up
and all of a sudden the brain moves into
those gamma patterns and that person
the heart is informing the brain the
heart is telling the brain it's safe to
create the heart is giving the brain
information we actually see this now the
brain the heart has Intelligence brain
thinks but the heart knows so all of a
sudden the heart says Emilio is time to
create you're out of survival
and you get these incredible ideas you
get the mystical moment you get the
understanding you get the download you
get whatever that is people can do that
now on command now why is that important
because you know most people are
stressed
in survival and unconscious in a program
and racing and rushing to try to make
that feeling of emptiness or pain go
away and there's and they're lost in the
illusion of Separation thinking they
need the outer environment to do it
chaos is happening you got to be the eye
of the storm you got to be relaxed and
out of survival and awake and heart and
brain coherence means relaxed and awake
so then we take our youth we're
investing in our youth right now because
they're going to be the leaders of our
future
we want to teach them what leadership
truly is from the heart we want to teach
them how to make changes that are
permanent we want them to consider the
whole we want them to come up with ideas
that we will be interested in supporting
and backing that will create that kind
of cultural change that takes place and
most importantly
that they get along with one another I
mean why can't we just get along with
each other take away all the
all the governments take away all of all
the different cultures and you see
people in like you see modern events a
thousand people two thousand people all
Races all all cultures we all get along
everybody loves everybody I mean that's
that's who we innately are the greatest
challenge uh when we have uh strong
emotions that are stored in the brain
and body is it's very difficult
uh to think greater than how we feel
that I think that is the challenge
and uh feelings are a record of the past
so so
the person if they can't think greater
than how they feel then they can't see a
possible future
because they're looking at that future
through the lens of their past biology
and so
best thing for a person to do if they're
truly truly committed to change is to
really understand what change means and
really understand that there's a biology
and a very specific explanation of what
change is okay so the person says I
didn't create this reality okay okay you
didn't create that reality uh I didn't
ask for the life that I'm living okay
you didn't ask for the life that you're
living okay
um
I didn't pick these parents somehow I
was born into this family okay great
so now what
I mean now what are I mean like if our
excuse to change is really it's that
person or that circumstance or that past
that's really making me feel this way
you can do that for a while
but if you start reading and learning
and filling your brain with knowledge
and making new Connections in your brain
you got more raw materials to start
thinking about new possibilities now
that's what information does information
every time you learn something new
you're making thousands of synaptic
Connections in your brain repeat it
review it think about it talk about it
share it and those circuits begin to
create long-term connections called
Memories and now you're adding more
three-dimensional stitches into the
tapestry of your gray matter and and
you're building information to see that
there are other ways to live now
pick up a book on someone who's had
trauma and they turn that trauma around
and they live their life in joy and then
and they see it differently and you're
picking up and relating with the story
and at the same time you're realizing
you're identifying with this character
and if they can do it you can do it too
all right so now the possibility exists
okay
now the person really who truly wants to
be happy says I can't I can't live in my
past any longer okay I understand that I
know it's hard and I'm gonna I'm gonna
default back to my old personality maybe
10 times or 20 times or a hundred times
in one day
that's okay because if I'm alive
tomorrow I'm gonna try and do it better
the next day I'm not gonna think act and
feel this way
so how many times do we have to forget
until we really stop forgetting and
start remembering
how many times do we go unconscious in
our waking day that we have to stop
going unconscious and stay conscious
so the person who no longer wants to be
and I hate to use this word victimized
by their life but
excusing themselves from the possibility
that there could be an alternative way
to live a new life to live in the person
who excuses themselves that way is
because they can't imagine a new life
greater than how they typically feel and
of course it takes trauma or disease or
diagnosis or loss or betrayal
for the person to be so knocked out of
balance that they finally say I have to
change
and they can tell you exactly where they
were the time of day it was who they
were with when they made up their mind
to change this happens thousands of
times in our research the person says
I'm making up my mind in this moment and
they make a decision with such firm
intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy that causes
their body to respond to their mind
that the choice that they're making in
that moment in time is a moment in time
they will never forget
in other words the stronger the emotion
they felt when they made that choice
independent of what was going on in
their environment and their life the
more they'll remember the choice they're
making that's what emotions do and that
gives the body a sampling or a taste of
the future they're changing their state
of being in one instant if your
personality creates your personal
reality and that means that if in order
for you to change your personal reality
you got to change your personality so
the one of the basic core principles of
our work is really uh this concept of
change and what is change how do we
change why is change so hard because we
all say it's hard yeah it changes hard I
used to say that too my Kevin's so good
at changing I'm not good at changing it
turns out I'm really good good at it
yeah once you know how yeah and you
understand the formula it gets very
simple to really all of a sudden sip
with yourself long enough this is what I
want people to do I want them to sit
with themselves long enough that they
can become so familiar with the word
meditation to become familiar with
to become so conscious of their
unconscious thoughts that they don't go
unconscious to them in their waking day
you know that belief like I can't why
can't I change it why is change so hard
for me
to become so aware of how they speak how
they act if they blame if they complain
if they make excuses they feel sorry for
them they judge people I want them to
sit with themselves and look at those
programs to become so conscious that
they don't default
and go unconscious again and then and
then sit long enough with those emotions
where you really don't reach for the
cell phone now and you're curious to see
what's on the other side of it or you're
given
a tool to help you get Beyond it right
if I give people numerous opportunities
to overcome themselves
because that's what it is and numerous
opportunities connect over and over
again sooner or later
it's going to start to create some
movement so then the person should then
in that place called The Unknown start
thinking about what thoughts they do on
a fire and wire in their brain and with
intention and attention when that voice
is saying I can it's too hard I'll never
change this becomes the louder voice
than that voice and nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together okay so if I keep that up I can
install Hardware that can become like a
software program which would be like the
new voice in my head that says Maria you
actually can change it's not that hard
you you actually prove that to yourself
by getting beyond that thought there's
something on the other side of it right
that's called The Unknown
if you close your eyes and thought about
how you were going to be in one day just
with your family with your relationships
with your job with your co-workers and
traffic how are you going to be like
what would greatness look like if you
took the time to really rehearse those
scenes in your mind you would do the
exact same thing as thinking about them
you would begin to install more Hardware
priming your brain for the ACT
to cause your brain to look like you've
already done it that's what the research
shows so I want people
to remind themselves of who they do want
to be and get very familiar with it fire
and wire fire and wire and then this
Focus equals feeling right so if you're
focusing on it non-stop you're going to
start to feel it which is the next thing
and the last thing then is which is the
toughest part for people because we've
been programmed and hypnotized into
waiting for the event out there to occur
to take away the lack or the pain that
we feel inside of us so the event
produces the experience of when the
wealth comes when the relationship comes
down I'm going to be happy Well turns
out you got to feel it in order for it
to happen in the quantum so if we can
teach people how to self-regulate their
emotional state right
and feel the feeling before the event
the body is so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and the emotion that that person is
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's living in a new
environment well
the research on epigenetics says it's
the environment that signals the gene
okay well the end product of an
experience from an environment is an
emotion so when people are embracing
these emotions ahead of the
environmental experience they're
signaling genes ahead of the environment
they're actually they're actually their
gratitude is actually healing them their
wholeness is moving them back towards
Health their empowerment is taking them
towards success they're they're
generating abundance they're feeling
more worthy and and and it turns out
when we measure what happens
there are dramatic biological changes
that take place in one week
that actually suggests that that person
is literally living in a new environment
and they're in a ballroom and there's
not a lot that happens in a ballroom and
I keep saying to the scientists
where are those chemicals coming from no
scientists will dispute the fact that
living in survival and living in stress
long term pushes the genetic buttons
that create disease that no organism in
nature can sustain emergency modes for
that experience for that extent of time
all other systems are compromised
because all the energy is going towards
survival
and if you can turn on that stress
response just by thoughts alone your
thoughts can make you sick
and she started to read and consume this
information and it made sense to her
scientific mind she understood she had
to get out of survival this is wasn't
like how come I'm not healing this is
like I have to get out of survival in
order to heal did you hear me
that's a fundamental point that has to
be understood
the next thing she does is she
experiments to see if I start making
changes in my internal state will my
body be so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the
environmental experience that's
producing the emotion and the emotion
that I'm creating by thought alone I
understand the environment signals the
gene okay the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion my goodness I could actually
signal genes ahead of the environment if
I give thanks for my healing before it
happens and all I'm going to do is
combine a clear intention a vision the
optimistic view that I could actually
get better with an elevated emotion
a thought and a Feeling
a image a symbol and an emotion a
conditioned response stimulus and
response and she's conditioning her body
emotionally every single day for it to
believe it's living in a new future and
by practicing the brain and heart
coherence she's creating autonomic
regulation instead of autonomic
dysregulation and the innate
intelligence of the body is that it
wants to heal
are you with me
and so then
she's in the process of discovery
of saying I'm not going to be a victim
to my disease I mean the prognosis would
normally create a lot of fear for people
a lot of stress for people a lot of
self-doubt for people
a lot of times you don't feel good
you're in a lot of pain you don't want
to do it
a lot of times you just don't want to
have enough time because you got to sit
with you and that doesn't feel good
sometimes
but
we have Physicians and nurses now and
scientists in this audience actually
that said well let me just see if I
actually apply this and just experiment
with the process just I'm not going to
try to make anything happen I'm just
going to follow the instructions and see
what happens if I do this she's not
she's not trying to control the outcome
she's actually curious to see as a if
there's another possibility she's not
forcing it she's not fighting for it
she's not trying to predict it she's
really just measuring the effects of her
at cause
if I change my internal state will I
start noticing changes in my biology I
don't know well let's just see if I
practice this what would happen
and if she starts the event five days
into the event she starts feeling better
it means she's dragging that body out of
the past
and some people just find that little
magic door
where their body all of a sudden
responds to their mind they reprogram
their body experience enriches the brain
now you're laying down circuits for
something that has nothing to do with
the material world and that experience
produces an emotion but the emotion is
not going to be guilt or shame or
unworthiness or fear the emotions are
going to be ecstasy or Bliss and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you're going to pay attention to those
pictures in your mind and literally
you're going to begin to rewire your
brain for the mystical and when you open
your eyes and you come back to your
senses you're going to see a broader
spectrum of reality you're going to
begin to see what has always existed but
you didn't have the circuits in place to
experience them because we don't see
things how they are we see things how we
are so now the person all of a sudden
opens their eyes and
I've had this happen you see colors and
light like you've never seen before you
hear everything's melodious everything's
unified so smell The Taste the feeling
of everything is just enhanced and we're
here
in three-dimensional reality for that
I mean we're here to really experience
life fully I mean that's why I'm here
that I'm not going to be guilty I'm not
going to be sad I mean we how many times
have we done that I mean that mystical
moment
um when you have that experience and you
begin to perceive a whole in a whole
different way
uh and and you connected to that
intelligence uh you will see that that
energy that intelligence in every human
being and everything around you and
you'll feel more connected and less
separate and I think that's uh and I
think that's why we're here your
personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel so the present
personality who's listening to this
podcast has created the present personal
reality called their life which means
that if you want to change your life you
want to create a new person in reality
you're gonna have to change your
personality you're gonna have to change
because nothing changes in your life
until you change so what is the
understanding of change that we've spent
over 10 years studying a way to explain
what change is because if you think 60
to 70 000 thoughts 90 of those thoughts
are the same thoughts as the day before
you're in trouble because the same
thoughts will lead to the same choices
the same choices will lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce those very very same
emotions and those same emotions
influence our same thoughts and our
biology everything stays the same
because we're the same I gotta change my
personality while this concept of
metacognition you know the seed of our
conscience our frontal lobe allows us to
think about what we're thinking about to
notice how we're behaving and to become
aware of how we're feeling and the
repetition of thinking acting and
feeling in the same way causes our brain
to become hardwired into very specific
neurode patterns right so the moment we
become conscious of those thoughts the
moment we become aware of those
behaviors the moments we notice those
feelings we're no longer the program in
fact part of the Consciousness observing
the program and that's the first step to
change I think that the demonstration
of greatness is so important right now
people are looking for it and they can't
find it anywhere and we can't wait
you cannot wait for someone else to lead
you got to show people what compassion
looks like you got to show them what
kindness looks like you got to show them
what equality looks like you got to
celebrate successes and others you you
we have to be that all the time so that
we give people permission to do the same
right so my hope
is that if we can change individuals
one by one we're going to change the
world and that's it and and and at the
end of a one week long event
I would say that 99 of the people that
come to that week-long event are not the
same person that got there now they go
back into their life
and all of a sudden they're not doing
anything differently but people say to
them all the time
what's up with you what happened to you
because you got a new job you know
whether you got a new girlfriend and a
boyfriend what's going on no nothing
because they're out of phase the memory
of that person is not matching the
projection of what they see in front of
them they're at a phase right so I've
got enough people
remembering that they're the creators of
their life that they actually do control
their emotions that they actually have
the ability no matter who they are
uh to to create the life they want in in
just making the time to do it is so
important so I have I have great hope at
this time in the world right now that
all the things that are falling apart
have to fall apart and our youth are
going to be our leaders and and that we
either demonstrate we're going to teach
them how to demonstrate what that looks
like then they have to be impeccable
when they do it we don't see things how
they are we see things how we are and so
the I I don't like to use the word
visualization because I think it's been
okay has been overused I like to use the
word mental rehearsal I don't care if
you're a virtuoso uh musician
I don't care if you are a performer or
an actor I don't care if you're a dancer
or an athlete everybody does this who's
engaged in getting better at whatever
they do they will rehearse the course
now or the re rehearse the ACT enough
times that once they can concept the
whole thing to its completion
and they get out of that think box then
the think box is so important because we
have to
review our act we have to repeat it
enough times and the act of mental
rehearsal really installs the
neurological Hardware in your brain it
primes the brain free so you have
circuits to use now mental rehearsal
also changes the body you can take a
group of men
and have them imagine or rehearse doing
bicep curls for an hour a day for two
weeks and add an emotional component
called stronger harder more intense and
for one hour they practice in their mind
doing those those curls at the end of
two weeks there's a 13.5 increase in
muscle strength they never lifted a
weight their bodies changing by thought
alone so the person who's priming their
brain and body through rehearsal
when they get in their play box there's
no thinking they're just doing there's
just the act in fact the thought of what
they're doing becomes the experience
they get lost in the act and they're
analytical facilities their analytical
mind is out of the way and they can they
can sustain a state where nothing in
their environment is going to move them
from the state they're in the feeling of
what it would feel like to play well and
they hold on to that feeling and when
the conditions get tense they actually
do something different they
self-regulate and they actually crave
this moment of performance to be able to
produce an outcome and so there's no
mysticism to this it's just what people
do when they get really into something
is that we rehearse all the time so when
people understand if you take a group of
people that never played the piano
before and you teach them one hand that
scales in chords and they come in
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you do a
brain stand and before and after they'll
grow circuits on the opposite side of
the brain no magic there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections you get your body involved
you get some instruction you have an
experience experience enriches the
circuits repeat it over and over again
fire and wire and pay attention and stay
present you'll assemble new neurological
circuitry
take another group of people have them
close their eyes an act that actually
have them mentally rehearse playing the
scales and chords for two hours a day
for five days scan their brain before
and after and the end of five days their
brain will look like they've been
playing the piano for five days but they
never lifted a finger the brain
literally changed through the rehearsal
okay so now take the person and put them
in front of a piano never played the
piano before and they could actually
play those scales and chords like the
people who are actually physically
demonstrating it so what does that have
to do for the single mother of three
children what does that have to do with
the person
who's trying to heal a health condition
it's not enough to just have a good
meditation and get up and spend the rest
of your day reacting and responding to
the conditions in your life that's one
hour of living and conditioning your
body and brain into the future against
15 hours of you and responding
emotionally from your past so we gotta
rehearse okay how am I going to be in
this situation how am I going to change
what would love do today what would
greatness look like it's the it's those
frontal lobe questions that actually
begins to install the circuitry and we
all do it naturally the only time we
don't do it is when we're living in
stress and we're living in survival why
because it's not a time to create it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
go inward uh it's not and not a time to
Dream It's a time to run fight and hide
and if you're spending the majority of
your time in the arousal of those stress
hormones
than most people then their senses
become heightened they narrow their
focus and now they're engaged in doing
anything they can relying on something
outside of them to take away that
feeling so if people begin to understand
that they actually can change and
there's a they understand a formula to
do it and they practice that formula and
they rehearse it both by mentally
rehearsing it and actually participating
in it the effects should be in the
experiment that something should change
either in your body or in your life and
that's why we do it so when you see the
changes or the synchronicities or the
coincidences or the opportunities
starting to show up in your life you're
going to pay attention to what you did
and you're going to do it again and many
people who have chronic health
conditions that just get Beyond those
thoughts and those habits and those
emotions that keep them as that same
personality and begin to think act and
feel differently
notice dramatic changes in their in
their health and in their biology and we
have the data to suggest that people who
do this for seven days their body looks
like genetically and biologically
they're in a different life their body
is no longer responding in the same way
and they're no longer victims to their
environment because they can
self-regulate there tends to be a
greater resistance
to anything in their environment even on
a microscopic level that means your
thoughts are literally going to make you
sick and the fundamental question is if
your thoughts can make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts can make you
well and that's kind of the interest
that I have and and we've done numerous
studies to show that you can take people
we did a study with 120 people and we
said okay
um here's what we're going to do
we're going to measure cortisol levels
we'll measure stress hormone levels
you're going to come to an event a
workshop for four days
and we're going to re-measure your
cortisol levels we measured another
chemical called IGA
immunoglobulin a it's the primary
defense in the body against bacteria and
viruses the body's natural flu shot in
fact it's better than a flu shot and we
innately make this but as cortisol
levels go up as stress hormones go up
your immune system is suppressed right
uh so we said okay let's change the
frustration the anger the impatience the
resentment whatever the emotion is
that's correlated with the hormones of
stress and let's do a heartfelt emotion
let's do gratitude appreciation kindness
uh thankfulness and let's let's start
self-regulating and and we put heart
rate monitors on them to make sure that
they were doing it everybody has done
this
at some point in their life right where
they have to catch the thought
they have to catch how they speak the
ACT they have to notice oh this is that
weird feeling again I'm not going to
just stay in this feeling can I change
it right so then if you remind yourself
every single day of who you no longer
want to be before you start your day
become conscious of your unconscious
self so conscious that you don't don't
go unconscious in your waking day the
next fundamental question is if your
personality creates your personal
reality
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and with attention with
presence and intention energy
begin to Fire and wire that thought if
you can fire and wire that thought you
start installing the neurological
Hardware in your brain keep doing it and
start acting acting like a software
program it becomes more automatic that's
the new voice in your head that says you
can it's possible or whatever and then
how are you going to behave in the zoom
meeting how are you going to behave with
your children how are you going to
behave with your ex how are you going to
be today when you open your eyes now
here's the cool part and you know this
the act of closing your eyes and
mentally rehearsing
who you're going to be planning your
actions in the day
mental rehearsal
shows that you could actually install
the neurological Hardware in your brain
to look like you already did it or it
already happened now the brain is no
longer a record of the past it now
becomes a map to the Future okay we've
all rehearsed something in our life and
our minds over and over again keep doing
it keep rehearsing it keep reviewing it
and it'll start to become more automatic
and you could actually program a person
then to behave as a happy person no
magic there you install the circuits now
here's the hardest part
can you teach your body emotionally
what that future would feel like before
it happens in other words don't wait for
your healing to feel gratitude don't
wait for your new relationship to feel
love don't wait for the mystical moment
to feel awe that's kind of the old model
of reality of cause and effect let's
wait for something out there to happen
to take away this emptiness this guilt
this lack the suffering whatever what if
I could condition my body emotionally
into the future so then we started
studying not only brain coherence but we
started studying heart coherence could a
person trade resentment and watch their
heart beat in a really irregular fashion
to a more coherent fashion where when
they're feeling gratitude when they're
feeling inspiration when they're feeling
love could they practice that enough
times so much so
they can condition their body into the
emotion of the future now here's the
cool part about that
our research shows you could absolutely
do that and do it so well that you feel
like the future that you're in wanting
to experience has already happened and
when it feels like it's already happened
you feel less separate from it which
means you're no longer looking for it
why would you look for it if you feel
like it's already happened now
to become familiar with the old self and
then fire and wire and condition the
body emotionally and chemically and
become familiar with the new self if
you're truly in the experiment of life
and I truly change my personality
there should be some evidence in my
world that there's been some change
either in my body and in my life in some
way and literally
their biology changes their their their
immune system changes they're we've
we've isolated thousands of metabolites
that show that that there's a
flourishing going on in the body the
body's responding it's believing
emotionally that it's living in a
different environment that's that's the
key
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Eckhart Tolle
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there